our series a more perfect beauty means
to show that what unites us as Americans
is really far greater than what divides
us so this morning we're going to
introduce you to a corporate executive
who spends his Saturdays teaching
technology with a little bit of a twist
CTM national correspondent and Jericka
Duncan stop by for a lesson jurika how
does this program work I saw you in high
heels moving you got moves
who knew it works because it's fun you
know the name of this program is called
dance logic for one our girls between
the ages of 13 and 17 dance and then
they spend the next hour learning how to
code you may wonder well how do these
two concepts go hand-in-hand take a look
one two the numbers so from right here
right steps and creativity are integral
parts of choreography and coding with
dancing you have to look at the steps
and figure out how do they fit into one
another sync of coding fourteen-year-old
naihla Shabazz is part of dance logic a
program in Philadelphia that combines
dance and computer programming or coding
basically if I see myself coding and
helping others I think I can also bring
in other people who look like me to also
want to pursue that's filled as well
this is 14 year old Lauren Dorsett's
second year she admits the dancing part
came easy the coding part is sort of
hard at first when you think about it
once you really grow into it and I stay
stay with it for a while it starts to
get easier so when you found out how
much you could potentially make later on
in life with these skills you thought
what I thought I should look more into
this book because not all fields
offering the same type of opportunities
you can get far with this and
opportunity is everything sets Franklin
Atheists he's a senior vice president at
Comcast who started dance logic in 2018
I have no idea what it was going to turn
out to be cuz originally you wanted to
focus just on coding right exactly
but his friend and co-founder Betty
Lindley who runs a cultural center
suggested he incorporate dance he was
teaching coding to children and youth in
the community but there was a problem he
had trouble getting them to participate
trying to find the hook because coding
alone doesn't bring the hook
alright and it worked the dance was
getting them to come back to the class
for people who look at something like
coding and they think I'm not good at
math I'm not good at science this is too
hard what do you say to that it's like
everything else all right it's always
hard in the beginning this is why the
dance part is so important because a lot
in young ladies came in it could not
dance but they practice I am here to
left feet for my father oh really
yes Oh your dad's watching you just put
him out there on national TV yes I did
but if I have the confidence to dance a
front of a bunch of people and not to be
afraid of making mistakes that I have
the confidence to accomplish whatever
goals I have in life both girls said
that it gave them confidence and they
felt like that helps them in the real
world because now they said I can do
anything exactly because something they
thought they thought was hard right now
became easy right and it was all because
of practice mm-hmm it wasn't anything
else besides let's try it let's get it
wrong let's try it again
and then boom the smile comes on your
face and say I got it mr. Frank then
they could say I can also do this and
the world is theirs because you cannot
find women in this field according to
the Pew Research Center women hold just
25% of computer-related occupations in
the u.s. new research projects that
number could fall to 22% by 2025
you're a senior vice president of a
major corporation and you're taking your
Saturdays to help young girls you could
be doing so many things I'm sure why do
you think it's so important to give back
I came from a very rough neighborhood
right and someone introduced me to
something that kept me out of trouble if
I can help motivate some other person to
do the same thing and show then it's not
that hard
all right that's the reward I get out of
this and when the girls finished the
14-week program they are rewarded you
now have an iPad a theist gives them
iPads so they can keep coding
it has no doubt they'll definitely keep
on dancing there is a tuition cost for
the program it's just $50 for a 14 week
session the West Park Cultural Center
the organization that runs dance logic
says it will never turn away anyone who
cannot afford the cost it offers
scholarships as well so you get the iPad
a scholarship and I think the real part
of this that makes it fun is the dancing
so it's like he said that's the hook and
the rest is good self-esteem you get
calm hearty love Franklin atheist even
though I feel like dancin code as a
class I would have failed twice but you
heard him say practice I love people who
realize that in learning you have to
open a door to somebody to let them in
it's opportunity it's just it's great
and he said everything is hard at first
it's true starting this tariqa thing